il a dit animations phrase marque obame
s commence est dangereux
moyens petits légumes car nation est une
icône je suis la reine d'angleterre
alors qui a dit cette phrase quelqu'un
qui déteste kim kardashian comme moi en
dali est ce que c'est une femme ah oui
c'est une française oui c'était on est
dans les eaux du nord assez marrant
quand énoncé prina levrat loin pas loin
pas loin on est dans le très haut la
fanny ardant paf a tourné autour qui il
reste plus qu isabelle adjani absolument
travaux
on s'est peut-être un petit brin de
jalousie quand même hein quand même
emporté à temps là je m'arrêtais trois
secondes à berne c'est quand même une
belle issue de sa non pas tant parce que
je veux qu'ils aient ce moment de
solitude donc isabelle adjani à 12 g est
une espèce d'amérique bruce america
payera cher c'est quand même une icône
de nos jours c'est une grande star je
pense que tout le monde sera d'accord
avec moi une mexicaine à sare des
raisons dans ce que tu es les icônes
aujourd'hui nc mais pourquoi mais
aujourd'hui une star des réseaux ou des
ça devient des icônes aujourd'hui rakeen
garda chiant ça fait partie des g à 6
mais tu connais la janais ou pas parce
que à isabelle adjani c'est quand même
une des salles et or this tard une belle
grande j'aurais pas tous en même temps
ils appellent à une plainte car la même
chose dans la belle peut être jaloux
chez ricard machin c'est une lentille
oignons oh la la c'est à peu près tout
pour venger sa ça isabelle adjani est
jalouse de ça fait vraiment je vous dis
un truc des dinka trois césars et qui
tient une icône française et mondiale
qu'a fait les plus belles pubs ont
mélangé
et on a une meuf qui a été connu pour
une sextape et qui incarna vulgarité
mais ça dérange personne que des
étendues par sa mère en plus salées
pendu par sa mère que je sais qu est de
qualité moi je moi j'aime beaucoup et
j'aime beaucoup elle aurait dû alors
outdoor commencer je suis très admiratif
de la carrière de cette fille devienne
kardashian elle a vraiment réussi à
transformer l'essai et elle devient
véritablement une icône mode en fait
aujourd'hui elle arrive à se transformer
elle arrive à faire des choses très très
très notamment je trouve que alors vous
savez je vous dis un truc moi je dois je
dois devenir vieille france parce que je
me souviens que plus jeune quand saint
laurent fait des défilés il y avait
catherine deneuve qui était assise pour
regarder le défilé qui sont 10 sacs à
main on est plus haut j'ai vu qu olivier
rousteing balmain m'étais kim kardashian
écrit la ville c'est l'icône de la mode
dans ce cas les banques et bear je meurs
mais c'est pas ça pardon mais tu dit
elle la carrière qu'elle a si je me
glisse à la fin de la casse et à la fin
de la carrière qu'on compte les bouses à
la fin du marché parce que là pour la
salle à une trentaine d'années mais de
la carrière n'est pas finie moi
j'attends de voir ce que ça va là elle a
déjà trente ans une carrière qui est qui
qui est incroyable enfin moi je pense à
des carrières guerrière et célébrités
l'actrice avait la chaleur pas tous en
même temps bree tayem qui justement à
nokia a travaillé un cas m à quoi bon
aller jusqu'au bout taf non j'allais pas
du bape qui est connu à m mr doit pas
rien même passé serait
elle un petit plaisir quoi qu'est la
même carrière au bon moment c'est bas en
terme d'argent mais en termes de débit
normal je pense tout dépend comment on
définit une star je pense que les deux
sont des stars dans leur domaine on peut
pas on peut pas nier le fait qu'aucun
kim kardashian a transformé l'essai
aujourd'hui qu'elle est respecté par les
plus grandes marques haute couture et
dans son domaine elle est une star qu'on
le veuille ou non tout comme isabelle
adjani que je respecte et que tu admires
est une star dans son domaine dans le
domaine du cinéma les deux sont des
stars dans leur domaine à proprement dit
laurent somme c'est un oui mais je suis
pas totalement pad amer avec ayem excuse
moi maintenant je suis d'accord avec toi
car on est toujours jugée en chaîne sans
fin excusez moi mais qui peut me citer 5
film d'isabelle adjani par le public est
là la connerie cinq films aller
lester fou qui ont 40 ans quatuor que
fait-elle doigts car à tous en même
temps c'est ouais ça ouais 45 au
restaurant juste un truc important îles
hawaï après on passe à autre chose elle
a l'une des plus petites filmographie
paradoxalement et actrice française mais
elle a cinq césars maison je pense qu'on
n'aura plus jamais mais tu sais bien sur
le coup du métier en finir
rapidement une star c'est quelqu'un qui
laisse une part de mystère quelque chose
d'un peu imperceptible qui est un
charisme qui est aussi un artiste comme
kardashian est une business woman et je
respecte totalement de ce qu'elle a fait
est un ami zabel adjani on ne peut pas
la mettre en comparaison bien sûr j'en
ai mis ses deux amis stop stop stop
entre a pas alors on ira pas on n'ira
pas plus loin vous m'avez vous m'avez
vaincu les années passées la région